Where do you go?
Hmm.
The kitchen sink,
the local bar,
the mineral rich springs of Bergamo,
Italy in the 21st century.
You don't have to go that far for fresh
water, but still supply is running out.
What if we didn't have to
worry about water consumption?
What if you could drink and
shower as much as you wanted?
What if a trip to the well and a trip
to the beach, we're one and the same.
You might give a lot for those privileges,
but how much would it really cost?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if
all seawater became fresh water.
The first big question we have to ask is
why is the ocean so salty to begin with?
Well, it wasn't always like that.
About 3.8 billion years ago,
Earth surface had finally cooled to the
point that water vapor turn to liquid,
no salt added. That's right. A
really, really long time ago.
The oceans were fresh water,
but that wasn't going to last.
Whenever it rains, carbon dioxide from
the air dissolves into the falling water.
This makes the rain slightly
acidic and when it falls,
it causes rocks to erode from their
rainwater slides towards nearby rivers and
streams taking loose salt and
minerals along with it. From there,
this runoff flows from
rivers into the ocean.
Add to that any additional salt and
minerals that would be expelled from
hydrothermal vents or submarine volcanoes,
and then consider that this whole
process has been recurring more or less
consistently for 3.8 billion years.
That's a lot of salt.
In fact,
there's so much salt in the ocean that
if you spread it evenly across all the
land on earth, it would amount
to one tower in layer of salt.
That's 40 stories tall.
97% of all the water on earth is salient
and we've got to assume it's for a
reason. So what would our world look
like if we took the salt out of the sea?
Fresh water oceans sure do.
Sounds like a godsend. Right now.
It's predicted that a third of the world
will be facing chronic water shortages
by 2025 at our current
rate of consumption,
the global demand for fresh
water doubles every 20 years.
So maybe freshwater oceans would actually
yield a good outcome this time. Nope.
Uh, c without salt would decimate marine
life and dramatically affect our weather
and temperatures making human life on
earth very difficult, if not impossible.
There are roughly (220) 800-0450 species
in the ocean and as many as 2 million
more to be discovered. But if the
ocean were to become desalinated,
we'd never find them.
Salt water,
fish and other ocean creatures evolve
to be able to drink salt water,
to stay hydrated and
get rid of excess salt.
Not all sea creatures
do this the same way,
but being able to pump out excess salt
is crucial to surviving in the ocean.
Some species like salmon have to
tolerate freshwater and salt water,
but for the most part,
all saltwater species would perish.
This includes underwater algae,
which believe it or not,
accounts for half the
photosynthesis that occurs on earth.
Photosynthesis plays a vital role
in supplying our planet with oxygen.
Since trees and plants convert carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere into the air,
we breathe. So without algae,
not only did we get less oxygen,
we also have a lot more carbon
dioxide in our atmosphere.
This intensification of the greenhouse
effect would make some parts of the world
unbearably hot. You definitely notice
this intense heat near the equator.
Since our ocean currents
wouldn't be circulating warm
water and air the way they
used to. Convection currents help warm
water from the equator get farther north.
While colder water from the north is
able to cool hotter areas down south.
At the equator,
warmer water can carry more salt.
So this denser water sinks lower while
cooler water flows over top of it.
And in the far north, the water
gets cold enough to freeze and form.
Sea ice salt gets left
behind as the water freezes,
and naturally this makes
colder water up north denser,
allowing it to sink to the bottom to
make room for the incoming warmer water
that's worked its way up from the south.
But without salt,
the whole process breaks down.
Earth's extremities would freeze
while weather around the equator would
intensify.
For one thing,
hurricanes would be a lot more frequent
and a lot more deadly. At this point,
our weather and our climate
would be totally different
from how we know it. Now,
how long would we survive to see
all these changes? Not long at all.
You'd either freeze, overheat, die in
a natural disaster or starve to death.
Yeah.
With significantly less photosynthesis
and climates that are either extremely
cold or extremely hot,
our weather would no longer support
the diverse plant life it has now.
The entire food chain would collapse.
Most species would die off,
including humans. Since crops we rely
on for sustenance would all disappear.
So when we say ocean
colonization is important,
don't take it with a grain of salt. Of
course we respect the scientific method,
so keep questioning the world and its
properties on land and beyond and come
back soon for another.
What if.